I've been trying to figure out what I
was gonna say here for months
because there's no bigger stage than Ted
it felt like getting my message right
and this moment was more important than
anything and so I searched and searched
for days on end trying to find the right
configuration of words and although
intellectually I could bullet point the
big ideas that I wanted to share about
me too and this movement that I found it
I kept finding myself falling short of
finding the heart I wanted to pour
myself into this moment and tell you why
even the possibility of healing or
interrupting sexual violence was worth
standing and fighting for I wanted to
rally you to your feet with an uplifting
speech about the important work of
fighting for the dignity and humanity of
survivors but I don't know if I have it
the reality is after soldiering through
the Supreme Court nomination process an
attack from the White House gross
mischaracterizations internet trolls and
the rallies and marches and
heart-wrenching testimonies I'm faced
with my own hard truth I'm numb and I'm
not surprised I've traveled all across
the world giving talks and like
clockwork after every event more than
one person approaches me so that they
can say their piece in private and I
always tried to reassure them now give
them local resources and a soft
reassurance that they're not alone and
this is their movement too I tell them
that we're stronger together and that
this is a movement
of survivors and advocates doing things
big and small every day
and more and more people are joining
this movement every single day that part
is clear people are putting their bodies
on the line and raising their voices to
say enough is enough so why do I feel
this way
well someone with credible accusations
of sexual violence against him was
confirmed to the Supreme Court of the
United States of America again the US
president who was caught on tape talking
about how he can grab women's body parts
wherever he wants however he wants can
call a survivor a liar at one of his
rallies in the crowds will roar and all
across the world we're meet sue has
taken off Australia and France Sweden
China and now India survivors of sexual
violence are all at once being heard and
then vilified and I've read article
after article by moaning wealthy white
men who have landed softly with their
golden parachutes following the
disclosure of their terrible behavior
and we're asked to consider their
futures
but what of survivors this movement is
constantly being called a watershed
moment or even a reckoning but I wake up
some days feeling like all evidence
points to the contrary it's hard not to
feel numb I suspect something you may
feel numb to but let me tell you what
else I know sometimes when you hear the
word numb you think of a void an absence
of feelings or even the inability to
feel but that's not always true
numbness can come from those memories
that creep up in your mind that you
can't fight off in the middle of the
night they can come from the tears that
are locked behind your eyes that you
won't give yourself permission to cry
for me numbness comes from looking in
the face of survivors and knowing
everything to say but having nothing
left to give it's measuring the
magnitude of this task ahead of you
versus your own wavering fortitude
numbness is not always the absence of
feeling sometimes it's an accumulation
of feelings and their survivors we often
have to hold the truth of what we
experienced but now we're all holding
something whether we want to or not our
colleagues are speaking up and speaking
out industries across the board
re-examining workplace culture and
families and friends are having hard
conversations about closely held truths
everybody is impacted and then there's
the backlash we've all heard it
the meatsuit movement is a witch hunt
right me too is dismantling due process
or me sue has created a gender war the
media has been consistent with headline
after headline that frames this movement
in ways that make it difficult to move
our work forward and right-wing pundits
and other critics have these talking
points that shift the focus away from
survivors so suddenly a movement that
was started to support all survivors of
sexual violence is being talked about
like it's a vindictive plot against men
and I'm like huh how did we get here
we have moved so far away from the
origins of this movement that started a
decade ago or even the intentions of the
hashtag that started just a year ago
that sometimes the meatsuit movement
that I hear some people talk about is
unrecognizable to me but be clear this
is a movement about the one in four
girls and the one in six boys who are
sexually assaulted every year and carry
those wounds into adulthood
it's about the 84 percent of trans women
who will be sexually assaulted this year
and the indigenous women who are three
and a half times more likely to be
sexually assaulted than any other group
or people with disabilities who are
seven times more likely to be sexually
abused it's about the 60% of black girls
like me who will be experiencing sexual
violence before they turn 18 and the
thousands and thousands of low-wage
workers who are being sexually harassed
right now on jobs that they can't afford
to quit this is a movement about the
far-reaching power of empathy and so
it's about the millions and millions of
people who one year ago raised their
hands to say me too and their hands are
still raised while the media that they
consume erases them and politicians who
they elected to represent them pivot
away from solutions it's understandable
that the push-pull of this unique
historical moment feels like an
emotional roller coaster that has
rendered many of us not this
accumulation of feelings that so many of
us are experiencing together across the
globe is collective trauma but
it is also the first step towards
actively building a world that we want
right now what we do with this thing
that we're all holding is the evidence
that this is bigger than a moment it's
the confirmation that we are in a
movement and the most powerful movements
have always been built around what's
possible not just claiming what is right
now trauma halts possibility movement
activates it dr. King famously quoted
Theodore Parker saying the arc of the
moral universe is long and it bends
toward justice we've all heard this
quote but somebody has to bend it the
possibility that we create in this
movement and others is the weight
leaning that arc in the right direction
movements create possibility and they
are built on vision my vision for the
meatsuit movement is a part of a
collective vision to see a world free of
sexual violence and I believe we can
build that world . but in order to get
there we have to dramatically shift a
culture that propagates the idea that
vulnerability is synonymous with
permission and that bodily autonomy is
not a basic human right in other words
we have to dismantle the building blocks
of sexual violence power and privilege
so much of what we hear about the me2
movement is about individual bad actors
or depraved isolated behavior and it
fails to recognize that anybody in a
position of power comes with privilege
and it renders those without that power
more vulnerable teachers and students
coaches and athletes
law enforcement and citizen parent and
child these are all relationships that
can have an incredible imbalance of
power but we reshape that imbalance by
speaking out against it in unison and by
creating spaces to speak truth to power
we have to re-educate ourselves and our
children to understand that power and
privilege doesn't always have to destroy
and take it can be used to serve and
build and we have to re-educate
ourselves to understand that
unequivocally every human being has the
right to walk through this life with
their full humanity intact part of the
work of the meatsuit movement is about
the restoration of that humanity for
survivors because the violence doesn't
end with the act the violence is also
the trauma that we hold after the act
remember trauma halts possibility it
serves to impede stagnates confuse and
kill so all work rethinks how we deal
with trauma for instance we don't
believe that survivors should tell the
details of their stories all the time
we shouldn't have to perform our pain
over and over again for the sake of your
awareness we also try to teach survivors
to not lean into their trauma but to
lean into the joy that they curate in
their lives instead and if you don't
find it create it and lean into that but
when your life has been touched by
trauma sometimes trying to find joy
feels like an insurmountable task now
imagine trying to complete that task
while world leaders are discrediting
your memories or the news media keeps
erasing your experience
or people continuously reduce you to
your pain movement activates possibility
this folklore my family like most black
folks about my great-great Grandaddy
Lawrence where he was born enslaved his
parents were enslaved and he had no
reason to believe that a black men in
America wouldn't die a slave and yet
legend has it that when he was freed by
his and slave as he walked from Georgia
to South Carolina so that he could find
a wife and child that he was separated
from and every time I hear this story I
think to myself how could he do this
wasn't he afraid that he would be
captured and killed by white vigilantes
or he would get there and they would be
gone and so I asked my grandmother once
why she thought that he took this
journey up and she said I guess he had
to believe it was possible I have been
propelled by possibility for most of my
life I am here because somebody starting
with my ancestors believed I was
possible in 2006 12 years ago I laid
across a mattress on my floor in my
one-bedroom apartment frustrated with
all the sexual violence that I saw in my
community I pulled out a piece of paper
and I wrote me two on the top of it and
I proceeded to write out an action plan
for building a movement based on empathy
between survivors that would help us
feel like we can heal that we weren't
the sum total of the things that happen
to us possibility is a gift yaar it
births new world and it births visions I
know some of y'all are tired because I'm
tired I'm exhausted
and I'm numb those who came before us
didn't win every fight but they didn't
let it kill their vision it fuelled it
so I can't stop and I'm asking you not
to stop either we all future generations
a world free of sexual violence I
believe we can build that world do you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]